netflix has released the teaser trailer
for cobra kai season 3
and although it's only about 20 seconds
long it reveals some crucial information
about the upcoming season
on the season 2 finale entitled no mercy
after the final tenet of the kobrakai
motto
an explosive brawl between cobra kai and
miyagi dough plunges the school into
chaos
the fight focuses on the season's main
conflicts and it particularly focuses on
the bad blood between miguel and robbie
the climax of the battle comes when
robbie brutally kicks his nemesis off a
balcony
after miguel attempts to show mercy the
blow sends miguel tumbling directly onto
the railing far below him and this harsh
landing seriously
injures him at the end of the episode
miguel is on life support and his future
looks bleak
miguel's injury is clearly going to have
ripple effects in the world of koba kai
johnny lawrence played by william zabka
is dealing with a ton of guilt over what
happened to his young student
but perhaps the biggest question on fans
minds is what is going to happen to
miguel himself
the season 3 teaser gives us some
answers but not much
it shows that miguel is still in a
hospital bed wearing extensive medical
equipment
but it leaves a question of his overall
health a mystery the teaser also shows
miguel opening his eyes so at the very
least
fans now know that he wakes up at some
point in season 3. the clip
conspicuously doesn't show him moving
any limbs however
based on the fight in the finale of
season 2 and the glimpse of miguel and
the teaser it seems entirely possible if
not probable that he's paralyzed the
trailer doesn't confirm miguel's
condition one way or the other
but because he took a nasty fall and
landed right on his back
it's fair to assume that he's hurt
pretty bad even before the teaser
trailer arrived many fans were
predicting that miguel will be paralyzed
in season three
miguel's fall clearly caused a lot of
damage and it caused doctors to put
miguel on life support falling from a
balcony and crashing onto a hard railing
probably broke some bones or severely
damaged miguel's spine and paralysis
would be a likely result from these
injuries
still it's also fair to have an
optimistic view of miguel's injuries
right now fans only know that he's badly
injured and the specifics of his
condition are unknown with so much room
for taos there's no way to know how
serious his condition is
people walk away from frightening falls
all the time plus like
any television show cobra kai isn't
firmly restricted by the laws of reality
it's entirely possible that miguel will
emerge from the hospital bed with his
ability to walk fully intact
sure that probably won't happen but it's
possible one thing we know for sure that
this request from the season 2 finale
probably won't be honored no more karate
okay
all right amanda i know you're right no
more karate
the thrilling conclusion to the previous
season left fans with many questions
and the teaser trailer for the show's
return only increased the intrigue
on top of everything both season 1 and
season 2 have teased the return of ali
mills now annie mills schwaber and
the final shot of the finale hinted that
she may finally enter the story
could johnny and daniel's old flame have
a hand in helping miguel recover
after all she is a surgeon for someone
who hasn't talked to ally in decades you
sure know an awful lot about her
i've seen her on facebook what's a
facebook
fans will just have to wait for the
return of cobra kai to discover how it
all plays out
thankfully they won't have to wait too
long cobra kai season 3 is set to arrive
on netflix on january 8th
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one